– In Ordnung, so machen wir’s.
Vielen, vielen Dank! Ja, euch auch! Ciao.
– Und?
– Ab nächster Woche bist du
offiziell in der Filmbranche tätig.
– Cool.
Und du sagst, es ist eine Serie.
Weißt du noch mehr darüber?
Worum geht es?
– Es ist ’ne Krimiserie,
aber nicht so ernst.
Mehr ’ne Krimikomödie.
– Eine Krimikomödie.
– Ja. Komödie. Una comedia.
In der Serie geht es um einen Kommissar,
der mit seinem Gegner
zusammenarbeiten muss.
Meistens ist das sehr komisch. Hin und
wieder wird es aber auch tragisch.
Ich schau die Serie eigentlich ganz gern
– wenn gerade keine Dokus laufen …
– Das klingt ja spannend.
– Ich glaube sogar, das Drehbuch
basiert auf einem Roman.
Die Serie ist also eine Buchverfilmung.
– Und wo läuft die Serie denn?
– Ja, im Fernsehen.
Und im Internet auch, glaub ich.
– Gut. Dann fange ich gleich an,
die Serie zu schauen.
– Sehr gut! Vorbereitung ist wichtig.
– Filmbranche …